pretty good how are y'all doing good
we're good we're good
can you hear me okay yeah absolutely
fine
okay so I have a couple of questions
it's kind of a two-parted question
so I know what you guys do a lot of is
kind of preaching to the choir
um do you think there's a constructive
conversation to have with Modern Woman
um
actually I prefer it when people call in
that disagree but it's it's usually more
people worry
but um
I I think there's like
at some point they're too far gone
but like there's some that maybe aren't
as you know what I'm saying like like
the ones that are younger I think maybe
like be like suede yeah but it's like a
35 35 32 it's like what what's gonna
change your opinion at that point
um I would say with like the younger
generation but like in general I just
tell guys to date younger because like
it's just easy they're less traumatized
less of a headache yeah yeah I think
there's a constructive conversation I
think the constructive conversation like
Pearl was saying is with the younger
generation
um excuse me sorry I don't think I don't
think that it's constructed with the
older generation because the older
generation like I was saying earlier on
this show in the show is the ones that
are going to try and destroy
anything that you built without their
ideology because they're they're
starting to realize now
oh damn I actually I I I chose the wrong
path right and so when you realize you
chose the wrong path and you have an ego
and pride you don't necessarily you
don't want to admit that you've done
wrong you don't want to admit that
you're you were in a wrong right so
these people that the older generation
are going to be the bitter old angry
depressed generation the younger
generation can can actually be saved I
think
yeah I I think so too
and then I wanted to ask also have you
guys found any points
um that resonated with younger women
yes
um really yes I I there was a specific
woman that was
on the show Once I don't remember her
name we've done so many shows so many
shows right
um but when I was speaking after the
show
chic she said to me you know what I have
never had anybody
speak
about this stuff in the way you guys
have spoken about it and it's kind of
opened my mind whereas her being I think
she was like 21 22.
and everything that she'd been fed to up
to that age had been you know the from
older but you don't think there's any
points that specifically resonate with
like women in general I can't think of
any uh like I would say like certain
women sure but women in general do you
know what it is po I think I think all
the points that we make resonated women
but they are so stubborn right that they
refuse to let it permeate they know
women in general know that what we're
saying makes sense
[Laughter]
yeah that's true they know they know it
right yeah
to let it let it permeate right and so
that's the thing it's like if you know
something makes it's like if you know
one plus one is two right and you're
fighting that
674. you still know you still know it's
two but because of the fact that you are
hanging all of your
I guess emotions on the fact is 674.
like you just won't say it's two you
know what I mean so I think most of the
women that come on the show know that
what we are saying makes sense however
they just they're so stubborn
and that's why I said and that's what
going back to what you say modern day
women are some of the most stubborn
they're the most stubborn yeah gone
they're some of the most stubborn and
vindictive and hard-headed women that
you'll ever come across that's what I've
personally come to realize
yeah because I feel like there's a lot
of finger pointing
and I think a men men listen and they're
like okay you know how can I work on
myself so how can I get six-pack a
six-pack how can I get six figures you
know to you know meet these standards
but whenever you say like okay but you
know I don't want you to dress like a
hoe and go out to the clubs every
weekend you know it's like that becomes
a problem like don't control how I dress
or you know just all those kinds of
things it's like it turns back on us and
I just feel like there's no wanting to
take like okay you know if I want you to
make 80 to 100 a year
I can you know be more modest around
yeah but you know what I mean yeah but
that's the uh the best thing about the
stubbornness women know that if they
want to keep their man just like men
know if they want to keep their woman
they're gonna have to be certain
um
compromises that have to be made the
problem is with them the problem is with
the modern day woman is they don't think
they need to compromise route for
anything or anyone they think they don't
it's like men are more than willing to
compromise oh 100 but yeah you see the
amount of whales that have boyfriends
right because they've compromised but
the modern day woman and that's why I
said at the beginning when we talk about
the feminism Fallout women are going to
be the ones that are most affected by
feminism not men it's these women that
have taken on this ideology that refused
to compromise that refuse to listen that
refused to even take on anything other
than the feminist idology
in a in 10 to 15 years they are going to
be the most angry and bitter individuals
that you will ever find and like I said
I'm going to tell you as a brother and
I'm going to tell all the women be very
careful of those women because they will
try to sabotage
everything
that has been built without it ideology
they're gonna they're gonna try and
sabotage your family they're going to
try and sabotage any family that's been
built without their ideology right
they're going to try and sabotage it
they're going to tell you they're going
to try and go for the women they're
going to tell the women that they're
quote unquote what pick means
right yeah we've already seen it they're
going to tell them that they're pygmies
they're going to tell them that you know
that's they're they're idiots they're
going to tell the men that they're
misogynistic they can tell the man that
they're patriarchal all this kind of all
of it is it's just sabotage all of these
modern day women are just trying to
sabotage because things are now being
built and people are now having a
different ideology to what they have
yeah because I feel like in 10 to 15
years
I'll still be able to get a girl that's
25. you know what I mean how do you know
25. there you go oh yo oh definitely
you're definitely 10 in 10 years you're
going to be 35 you you'll definitely get
a 25 year old no no yeah oh no problem
those women are still going to be 35 40
right they're going to be 35 40. looking
at you saying looking at you telling you
oh my God you're a pedophile because you
want to get with it
right that's what I'm saying they're
going to do anything to sabotage and I'm
and I'm telling people from now the the
modern day the modern day feminist Ultra
feminist Super Saiyan feminist in 10 to
15 years is going to be the most
vindictive evil woman that you would
ever come across she's gonna try and
sabotage everything the best part is
she'll sabotage younger women yeah
that's like that's it that pisses me off
above all else is like when older women
sabotage younger women it's like if
you're gonna
if you're going to take owls can you
just take the L's and like at least
teach the Next Generation like that's
what I appreciate about Auntie like she
was a single mother I love yeah but she
was a single mother but she'll come like
she'll come out and say no I shouldn't
have been like I made poor decisions
right and that's and that's the thing
like like modern women will die on the
hill that they've never 100 they would
die and try and bring other people to
die with them yeah misery loves you yeah
misery loves company that will bring all
of the other yeah going sorry bro no
good I that's why I like when you I mean
it's kind of rude I guess but when you
say whales it's like it's not healthy or
cute or cool to be out of shape
no you know what I mean and it's like
and any woman that's saying like you go
girl body positivity it's like no you're
saying that because you're 130 pounds
well and it's one thing making fun of
someone for something they can't change
but like honestly if they got called
like I was I was anti sometimes like
she's very blind but it's kind of
helpful because it's like when someone
makes fun of you for something you want
to change it right and are you working
that bullying they said I'm not saying
I'm like some of y'all never have
brother brothers to bully you and it
shows it shows honestly I believe my
sister I'm gonna I'm gonna lie yeah yeah
I'll call my brother now and thank him
yeah
but yeah I mean it's like you know I
can't change how tall I am but it's not
a problem to hear women say you oh you
aren't six foot
right but I can't say like you need to
lose a little bit of weight or like I
don't want to be with you anymore you
put on 50 60 pounds and they can change
that that's not okay
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible